My name is Kaylin Golchini,
and I'm the Academy anchor
on the red carpet of Sing 2.
Tori Kelly, oh my God, I'm
such a big fan of her.
Hi, it's so good to
meet you.
You too. Kaylin
you look amazing.
You are the first
celebrity I’ve met.
I am?
Oh my goodness!
Who's your
favorite character?
My favorite character is
Ash and you.
Thank you.
Hey!
Wow. “That’s your enemy”
is that what you said?
No they’re with the Academy.
Oh, with the Academy.
Hello!
You’re shivering.
Yeah.
They’ve got to give you
a space heater
or something.
Campbell's soup?
You are my favorite
character in the movie.
Oh yay!
Yes, that’s awesome.
(music)
Oh, my goodness.
What's your name?
My name's Kaylin Golchini
and I think you're a star.
Oh, thank you.
I can’t wait to meet
the two legends.
How is it
singing with Bono?
When I was your age,
I was like the biggest
fan of his band, U2,
and so it was like
my dream come true.
So if it could
happen to me,
it could happen to you!
Who would you
want to sing with?
I would want to
sing with you.
No way!
I got you an early
Christmas gift.
Can I open it now?
Yeah!
I think you earned it.
Did you get me an Oscar?
Proud moment.
Shall I just
walk up and down?
I think he likes it.
I just want to say you're
amazing and hilarious
at changing your voice.
(funny voice)
Thank you so much.
Beep beep boop boop.
Was that good?
That's amazing!
He did the “beep beep”
Do adults love animated
movies just as kids do?
I think so.
Animation has been
around for 100 years,
so adults grew
up on animation.
And adults are
always looking for
something to do
with their kids
and also
distract their kids
because they're
very tired.
Their kids
are killing them.
Slowly. It's a slow
death, but they're
the kids are designed
to replace the adults
and they're just
tearing them down.
So, you know,
when you have kids, you're
just so exhausted.
Anything that gets
your kid’s attention
you're like, “thank God.”
Yeah something
to think about.
It’s a lot.
It’s heavy.
Nice meeting you.
Yeah thanks, I think that's
where we should end it.
(laughter)
That's a wrap!
Back to you Academy.